well you know what's um what's funny is
that we haven't had a video from our our
our friend dayton hypernova
uh for those who don't know maybe new
listeners dayton hypernova
europe uh cage paradoxa the man of many
names
cipher cypher hasn't made a video put a
video up on his youtube in a month and a
half and we were worried
well we have a new video we were doing a
concern
we have a new video finally of him
um how's the big homie doing well it's
good now the thing is with this video
it's unlisted
but we're going to watch it anyway
but we're just going to yeah i'm going
to read the title
packages with no from address keep
arriving to me and i'm not touching
anything from internet stalkers
you know his videos always start weird
with noises there's nothing on the
screen right now yet there will be
though
it sounds like remember that the first
the slim shady lp when he was dragging
his wife
through the woods you know what i was
gonna say though no honestly it actually
sounds like the sound the weird
does anybody remember smells like
children by marilyn manson yeah
but it was like a weird album it was
mostly him just [ __ ] around with an
experimental sound sampler right that's
what it sounds like that album was just
full of weird grinding noises
and like weird voices and mumbling like
that's what this feels like somebody
says it sounds like nighttime and rust
does oh it looks like night time in
russia
it does you can't see it it's just a
black screen like i guess this is it for
15 minutes
so he's talking to his dad if we get any
more parties in the mail that have no
return address them and don't question
it
in fact i would recommend telling the
mailman ring the doorbell
and if there's none take it back
[Music]
somebody apparently somebody mailed him
a bible
somebody mailed him a bible guys this is
why i love
people around like when we find like our
audience
is pretty slick about like i'm not gonna
do anything
[ __ ] no nothing wrong yeah you do need
christ son
you know like it's just one of those
things you're like it's pretty obnoxious
but
you got a free bible that's not a bad
gift but for somebody like that it's
obviously an obnoxious thing of course
it's like your son have a bible because
nobody's gonna go like hey
you leave him alone it's like what is
being a nice guy he needs a bible
people in the mail a bible yeah it's a
bible
well that sounds fine that's the third
package
i'm not touching any more
it was a bible with his name on it so it
was one of those
you know how you which one
the whole the whole it was a bible with
which name on it son
daughter person it was earl
it's not normal i didn't order that and
that was after the other ones
don't touch any of it don't get used to
all the things to be ashamed of that's
the thing
i did not order that gross
as far as anything i would tell you if i
ordered something anyway
because i would have been using your
credit card and you would have figured
it out you wouldn't have told them they
would have received it on a credit card
statement
that's not the pizza you buying bibles
and pizzas again
and girls clothes that's weird
don't worry we get clat we get vintage
earl here in a second
you think it's over it's not we get
vintage or up here i'm in this house
where they beat me
and it hits me is he gonna go right back
into it
oh right back yes
by the way not many people know this is
actually a foley artist making these
noises
i was going to ask is this a haunted
house
well it is it is haunted you're right
it's like fully working
i feel like i'm listening to a radio
show
where they're like and then the vampire
stalked him throughout the house
orson welles should be [ __ ] narrating
this
here it is here we go
weird packages in the mail this week in
my speaker i don't know
so i i'm telling my parents don't accept
any more packages that have no return
address or no from address
that have like a name on it directed to
me
don't accept anything because that's
terrifying they receive the bible
verified you don't say i'm like
i didn't order a bible that has like my
name on the address and has an overturn
address it's terrible
because that's
just bad scary i mean to have stalkers
now at this point like that is
horrible keeping out of the closet say
the line bart
that's horrible say the line my older
brother who beats me in this house
he did it he did it he did it he said
the line
and that's it that's the end of the
video that's the advantage earl
i like it so guys for those who worried
he's still around
he just k paradoxa doesn't understand
how unlisted videos work
apparently not kid paradox that doesn't
but you gonna learn
you cuco learned
so this is fun oh a little bit of
light-hearted whimsy on a friday yeah
that was
great kate paradox he's back we like
girl he's the best